tonight we are endorsing kamala d harris
for the 2024 democratic primaries she
deserves it and so did democrats they
created her they should be forced to
live with her and anyone who disagrees
with that is by definition a racist
candace owens is the founder of the
charity black sit she joins us tonight
it's a little weird candace owens to see
the democratic party people like david
axelrod and joe scarborough and the
whole brain trust whip around
and attack with great venom the highest
ranking woman of color in the united
states
you know tucker i don't have to answer
your questions i'm black i'm a woman i
like hip-hop i don't have to answer
everything that you're saying coherently
but yeah this is i i feel like i have to
actually defend these people i have to
defend the left on this one kamala
harris she did kind of slip through the
cracks even for me i was so focused in
the presidential election on joe biden's
mental faculties that i didn't realize
that you know she was just you know
completely daft it actually startled me
after the election to keep hearing her
speak to have nothing make any sense so
i think that they're all standing around
going whoa we had no idea we were all
worried about biden we had no idea that
kamala was such a fool and i have to
agree with you i'm going to have to
endorse her as a democratic nominee in
2024. we need more kamala harris you
know 100 you get 81 million votes
yeah she's the most popular vice
president ever and i do have to speak to
what you were saying earlier tucker
people always say that biden is fit is
failing america that biden has been a
failure and actually i asked them by
what metric by our metrics yes right we
go to the grocery store we see the we
see the prices we go to fill up our
tanks we see the prices then we have
people that are looking us in the face
like their press secretary which by the
way did i mention she's black and a
woman we should just say that because
it's very important that we we also
acknowledge that um but and they look at
my face and they said that we're in the
midst of an economic boom well they put
biden there for a reason and i honestly
believe that he is by their metrics by
the less metrics he's a great success i
think he was installed just like kamala
harris in an effort to deplete the
middle class to make people suffer to
make sure that people were relying more
on the government and by those metrics
actually they've been a tremendous
success to keep looking at us like we're
stupid and keep gaslighting the american
people and saying what are you talking
about everything's great we're in the
midst of the most historic economic boom
yeah by those metrics they've been a
great success i think that's really i
think you're absolutely right none of us
i certainly i was not wise enough to see
their intent but it's very obvious now
kenneth stones great to see you tonight
thank you very much
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight